You know that when people say, how did you get, you know,
suburban women and how do you get minorities and how do you get Democrats and
independents to vote for a Republican? Uh,
but I think it's one of the things that Republican party is going to have to
think about how do we reach out to a wider group of people in order to win
elections in the future? So we can be in a position of making decisions.
Do you think bottom line,
when you get rid of all the other issues that you're dealing with all day,
that if you,
as a governor can keep the economy chugging and keep people at work that you've
basically done your.
Well, we, you know, we're wrestling with all kinds of really tough issues. Dave,
when you're governor of the state, as I mentioned, you know, we're dealing with,
uh, you know, close to a $50 billion budget and, you know,
60 some thousand employees,
we have to provide all these different services are so many different issues,
but really it is we're dealing with educating folks and handling transportation
and, you know, law enforcement, all these multitude of things. Uh,
but the,
the focus that brought everybody together in our state that they could agree on,
they could argue about various, uh, you know, different issues.
But the one thing they all agreed on was the pocket book issues.
And that's how I put together. I put a group together called change, Maryland.
It was a nonpartisan citizen organization.
And we had just as many Democrats and independence as Republicans.
And they were just saying, let's focus on these issues.
Let's not argue about all these other things right now.
Let's just focus on this. And, uh, we brought together a coalition.
It turned out to be a winning coalition and, and, uh, you know, they,
when people say, how did you get, you know,
suburban women and how do you get minorities and how do you get Democrats and
independents to vote for a Republican? Uh,
but I think it's one of the things that Republican party is going to have to
think about how do we reach out to a wider group of people in order to win
elections in the future? So we can be in the position of making decisions.
Yeah. So I want to get more to that and the,
the sort of pure political side in a minute, but let, let's talk about what's,
what's going.
To get too political on your day.
A governor getting political. I can't believe it.
Yeah, let's do that anymore. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's, let's talk about what's going on now though, because, uh, you know,
there's been, I think the major conversation really, um,
at a high level is sort of what the federal government is supposed to do related
to coronavirus and what the state governments are supposed to
do. Um, I suspect, I generally know your thoughts on this, but,
but what do you think your job as a governor is write down what is not your job?
What is the job of the federal.
Government? Why is a great question? Look,
I think that governors are on the front lines of this crisis and we ought to be
we're we're. We are out there, we're closest to the people's problems.
We're working together with our, our local governments.
And we're trying to really address these issues that are on the ground in our
individual States. And each of our States are different we're we're going after,
you know, the different, uh, situations on the ground in our States. Um,
but there was, there was a major,
there were certain big things that only the federal government could do well.
So, you know, early on in this crisis, um,
the federal government could have taken more of a role in an overall testing
strategy. They did, you know, they were a little bit, I think,
behind the eight ball on, um, in the early stages.
And I talk about this in my book a little bit in March and April when they
weren't taking it as seriously. I mean,
there were people in the administration who were,
I think the president downplayed it a little more than he should have,
and they didn't develop a lot of national strategies.
We had 50 individual state strategies.
I'm not saying States shouldn't have had the authority and independence to be
able to make their own decisions,
but certain things like we shouldn't have 50 States competing with one another
in a constrained market for desperately needed supplies,
competing with the federal government and trying to acquire things all over the
world. Um, so on testing and contact tracing,
and some of the major issues that the power of the federal government could
really have helped with the pandemic.
And in some respects they're getting better. Um,
but certain things the federal government can just do better.
Can you talk a little bit about how you specifically make decisions when
it comes to lock down or the rest of it? Because as you know,
I'm here in Los Angeles, California, we've had rolling lockdowns,
then they kicked in again,
last week I was actually out to lunch for the first time in weeks.
And as I was having lunch, we got the notification on my phone that said,
the restaurants are closing in two hours. Now everything's closed again.
And I've been very critical of Gavin Newsome our governor here,
not necessarily because of what he's doing rather than the messaging.
It seems like they just, they just give edicts. They never say, well,
we've seen these numbers change this way.
We know this behavior change this or that. It's just, Oh,
now we're locking down. We'll see you in August. We'll see you in September.
And, and that's what I'm sort of more concerned about.
Can you talk a little bit about how you message things and how you actually come
to the decisions?
Yeah, it was great question, Dave,
and you hit on a couple of really good points. First of all,
I agree that the messaging has been a problem on B. You know,
I think a lot of the governors are not messaging very well. And frankly,
I think that's where the president's bigness biggest weaknesses have been on the
messaging side. Um, I,
I've tried to be just very direct and upfront and provide as much information as
possible because I think most people, uh, whether the, the,
the news is good or bad, if you're, if you're just, you know,
Frank with them and you supply the facts in a situation like this,
when we're dealing with, you know, in some cases,
life and death matters in a serious health crisis and a global pandemic and an
economic collapse, potentially. Um,
people want to know the facts and they want to know why you're making decisions.
So, you know, I think I'm not the only one doing it,
but there number the governors who have been more direct and open and
transparent,
I think I've been the most successful on the decision-making process.
I just tried to get, um, you know,
we had to make decisions really quickly in this thing because it wasn't like we
have deliberations with our legislature and let's talk about it and form a
committee. You know, this was happening really fast at the beginning.
As we were spiking, we were seeing things happening in Italy,
in New York and people dying and body stacked up and overflowing hospitals.
And we were hearing these things about 2 million potential deaths.
And so we were, it was speed time. It was of the essence to make some decisions.
Um, you had to make the right decisions quickly. You couldn't hesitate,
but I wanted to get the best advice I could from the smartest people.
We put together a task force of really smart doctors and scientists and business
people. And, and I just tried to get the best input.
It listened to everyone and then make decisions without hesitating, um,
and then communicate it really well to the people about this is what we're
doing, and here's why, and here's how it's going to help.
And so we took very aggressive and early actions did things that I never would
have imagined ever doing, but it helped us flatten the curve. I mean,
our numbers are really good. Our economy's really good. Uh,
we took early and aggressive action.
We'd had a safe and effective reopening and, uh, you know, we're now, you know,
way down from our peak, that happened about more than 90 days ago.
We've opened up 98% of our economy.
And our unemployment at 8% is staggering, but it's, it's, you know,
some States are two and a half times worse, better than the rest of the country.
Um, and, and our numbers, well, you know,
we we've had a number of deaths and we had the same problems other people had
we're in great shape right now.
Yeah.
On a personal note as a guy that didn't want to always get into politics when
you have to make those decisions about, okay,
we're going to extend the lock down, we're going to lift the lockdown,
whatever it may be. Um, what was that like for you?
Because I think people think of P people think of politicians sort of as robots,
like, Oh, they just make the choices, but yeah.
Yeah, no, it, it was really, really hard. David's, you know,
I've been through and I talk about some of these, you know,
personal and professional struggles battles that I've been through in my book.
And I share some of that, you know, what it was like, and,
and all the things that I had to deal with on a personal level or what battles I
went through as governor or getting elected governor.
This was the hardest thing that I think I've had to deal with. Um,
something we never imagined dealing with. And it wasn't just, you know,
I went through a cancer battle where I was worried about how my family was going
to take it, or, you know, w w what was,
I was dealing with other cancer patients,
but this was what I was worried about 6 million people in my state.
And my decisions were going to impact not only their health, but I'm a lifelong,
small business guy,
ran for governor with the sole purpose of creating jobs and helping small
businesses and decisions I was going to make,
we're going to impact it was going to cost people,
jobs and hurt their small businesses, or people were going to die. Um,
it, it was a really hard situation to be put in. And, and frankly,
the president, um, et cetera, still left it up. He said,
it's up to the governors. And we were getting, you know, um, you know,
open up and then, you know, but you have to shut down.
He was giving him th th the administration was given us advice.
You have to do these things, or we're going to have 2 million deaths. And then,
uh, you know, messaging the opposite stuff the next day. So it was,
we were in tough situations, but I think,
and everybody made different decisions, but, uh, on a personal level, I mean,
it's, there's been very little sleep for five months and a lot of stress.
And you got people that are mad at you either way, no matter what you do,
you can't make everybody happy. And, um, you know,
I just tried to do the very best I could, based on the information I had and,
um, you know, try to do the best thing for, for the people in the state.
Yeah. So let's talk about the other thing that's going on.
Cause there is another thing going on. There's always a lot of things,
but there's sort of two main ones going on at the moment.
And the second one obviously is I guess the best way to
describe it is either the racial unrest or the protesting or the rioting,
just the whole conversation we're having the, the toppling of, of monuments.
Now, again, you're in Maryland D C's right there. Awful lot of monuments, awful.
Lot of history is right in your backyard. Um, you know, you've got,
you've got Baltimore there, which has its own set of set of problems. Um,
so I'm not even going to ask you a question.
I'm just going to ha I'm going to just pass all that off to you. Take it away.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, that was, that's what you were just going to let me tee it up.
And, um, so I, I, you know, you look at the title of the book. It's like riots,
you know, cancer riots, a global pandemic.
I dealt with this and I talk about this a lot and there's real parallels to
what's going on right now with the, the riots, the, the violence, the,
the unrest, the protests, or however you want to describe it.
There's a little bit of all of that going on across America,
in different cities.
We're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.